the number one variable of growing your
business in this room that is practical
achievable doable
is how serious you take making content
on the internet
it's
that simple
no matter
what anybody in this room says to me of
why no because they've never started and
they have an ideology or because they've
made 45 posts on instagram and haven't
sold anything yet
no matter what your excuses
i promise you social media is not broken
in that story you're the one that's
broken
you've got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
one of the great things about kovid is
it breaks your patterns right something
that
monumental obviously there's so many
things that are challenging and
difficult and obviously devastating
but when you're able to make it to the
other side of a war or a pandemic or a
challenging time in one's life
there what was specific about this
pandemic was it gave you time to kind of
slow down even if you were panicking up
front incl which is what i was doing you
know literally within the first couple
days
of the shutdown four of our top five
clients emailed us and said we're not
going to be paying you for a while and
the way i build my company is for top
line growth i'm incredibly not
incentivized for profit which means
we're running on very tight margin so
not getting paid
is always a challenge and then on top of
everything else
vayner's size was very
very unique in that we were not small
enough and not big enough so we got 0.0
dollars from anybody and so we had to
navigate and after all that was done
and what is the framework of so much of
what i'm thinking about now started to
emerge and
you know the reality is is that
i can sit here
knowing this industry extremely well
knowing
the enormity of the advantage of this
room
because there's so many immigrants in
the room and that intro is absolutely
true
life is about
understanding the alternative
it's really hard
to complain about what milk was put in
your starbucks when you came from the
[ __ ] dirt
so
so you know there's a lot that we don't
need to touch on in this room
i could talk about
what i think you should be doing from a
content standpoint because the reality
is i promise you
the number one variable of growing your
business in this room that is practical
achievable doable
is how serious you take making content
on the internet
it's
that simple
no matter
what anybody in this room says to me of
why no because they've never started and
they have an ideology or because they've
made 45 posts on instagram and haven't
sold anything yet
no matter what your excuses
i promise you
social media is not broken in that story
you're the one that's broken it was
funny last week someone's like gary my
you've been talking about linkedin and
he showed me
the posts and he's like it's not working
and in the post i'm talking about making
content in the feed of linkedin
knowing who you're trying to reach
running ads against the employees of
those organizations for content in the
feed
and then i ask him what he's doing
and he's spamming people
by paying 100 bucks a month for a script
that just emails people on linkedin
that little story is something i think
about every day
the roi i like to say of a basketball
is billions of dollars for lebron james
it's zero for me
how one plays with the tools is the
variable of success
and so
we can get into the mindset very much
the intro which was lovely thank you and
in depth
i i do believe
that the far majority
of what is the opportunity in this room
or the limitation
sits in two very simple categories one's
uncomfortably black and white
and one is remarkably gray
the black and white is what i just
started with
until
you start making
dozens of videos pictures
and written articles a week you will
continue to leave an extraordinary
amount of money on the table and
somebody sitting next to you is going to
do it and take your market share and i
don't care if you've been the queen of
that city for 30 years and work on your
reputation slowly but surely you will
lose because that's what always happens
in business
if that wasn't the case ibm would still
be winning i i love this industry and i
love og's because my dad's an og [ __ ]
ami i started so young i'm an og like i
love og life and it is absolutely
building on reputation but i love when
an agent says to me dear you don't get
it i dominate this town for the last 30
years i'm like dear you don't get it
you don't get it much bigger companies
than you have gone out of business with
[ __ ] audacity
and it is audacity
in 2022.
it is it is only and this is very clear
if you're sitting in the crowd and
you're not doing this work it's only two
things and they're both interesting
one is audacity
you're audacious that what you did in
1993 or 2001 or 2007 is enough for you
to dominate 2022
or
you've lost your ambition which is okay
i don't think of that as a bad thing
i don't think it's a bad thing that
you're not as hungry
maybe you've scratched your itch maybe
you do want to do other parts in your
life
but look don't lie to yourself
and understand yourself on where you are
in your journey
2022 is going to be a remarkable
opportunity for this room
the question is very simple though who's
going to actually put in the 30 hours of
work starting today to actually know how
to do pictures and videos and written
words on these platforms and who's not
and it becomes a very simple game it's a
black and white prescriptive game either
you're good at it or you're not no
different than basketball we need to
have a very big conversation in the
business world about how much
kindness compassion empathy are the
superpowers of business people don't
think so
when i talk about kindness and i talk
about a lot my favorite email is like
title all caps gary you're wrong
i'm like here we go
i open it up you don't get it gary you
talk about kindness i'm always kind and
everybody takes advantage of me and
walks all over me and i reply
hey rick
maybe you're manipulating the situation
because you want somebody to walk all
over you a little bit because you're
actually subconsciously trying to create
leverage
because let me promise you one thing
about actual kindness if you're confused
by the definition
actual kindness
means giving
without expectation
and i believe in business what is very
clear to me is people think kindness
and they use kindness but what it really
is is a slight version of manipulation
you're doing something
with thinking something else is gonna
happen
you're referring because you think
you're gonna i and it's all good it's
nice to maybe think but
don't confuse that with kindness that's
called strategy
don't say you're kind say you're
throwing out reels and trying to hope it
returns
own what it actually is i was at a
conference like this many years ago and
i had just invested in uber
and it was the taxi and limo national
convention so i'm giving my talk
and i finally throw it out there and as
you can imagine
the room wasn't thrilled with me
but it was a discussion and all i saw
all i saw
was question after question statement
after statement
that was
why it wasn't gonna work
and all of the answers
were regulation
gary this is not going to work
because we're going to pay the
politicians off
similar to how i hear
car dealerships and car people talk
about tesla or direct to consumer
i promise you
when technology is coming along
hoping for regulation
is always going to be a bad strategy
my favorite is everybody who hates big
government because they're an
entrepreneur but then when something
comes along and [ __ ] you up you love
the government don't you
so when the blockchain comes and starts
taking out fees you better shut your
[ __ ] mouth in this room
and notice how few claps just happened
why do i bring that up right now not to
razz not to
scare because i want you to do the 50
hours of homework so you can innovate
what blows my mind is people's inability
to put in the work in the face of
information
all of you know that this blockchain
thing is brewing you've definitely heard
about bitcoin at this point you've
probably maybe heard of ethereum it's
happening and it's going to affect this
industry soonest
this is the book industry for the
internet the blockchain is contracts
understand that
please it's a very important thing
please spend 15 hours googling ethereum
and smart contracts get educated
not to play defense
but to play offense you do 15 to 30
hours of homework you might just change
your career
you might shift slightly in what you're
doing now to something else
it's a remarkable time and one thing i
know about an immigrant-centric reality
is it's not scared to put in the work
and i really know this statement
it likes to pick which work it wants to
do
people don't like change
and change is the only guarantee what
the blockchain eventually will do
is change the face of what brokerages
leverages in the ecosystem
right now is the time to build your
personal brand on the internet
and i mean right now
how you do that can be totally different
you don't need to be over the top or
curse like me you need to be you
i'm me
you be you
but what you need to do is start
producing content to educate people on
who you are
if you're uncomfortable with the way you
look and you want don't want to be on
video then do audio and do a podcast
if you're not sure that you can handle
the camera then write on linkedin or
facebook
if you feel more comfortable being the
hostess with the mostest start a
facebook group regionally within your
area one of the greatest arbitrages in
this industry right now is starting a
facebook group for the local area where
you sell
around the town not around selling homes
bringing people in building community
and then just happening to be the person
that's hosting that group
and picking up the business
these are the black and white tactics
available to you
how you build your team and how much
empathy you have for the consumer on the
other side is the other variable but the
opportunity is staggering it is
staggering
the speed in which people are changing
what they consume which then dictates
what they think which then dictates how
they buy
is at a level we've never seen before
i come here
fly across the country and fly back
for one reason to put so much pressure
on this room to do the homework
to do the homework
i mean it
the
the opportunity is so real
you are literally one
one
because i'm on the receiving end of
these messages you're one viral
tick-tock video away from selling 13
homes because of it
and you don't go in there and start
doing the latest dance you're trying to
sell homes
and you're more than welcome to shake
your ass fine but
but it's a lot more interesting to talk
about what you want to talk about
but making it contextual to the room
people say no so much
face excuse me tick tock's fastest
growing demo is 38 to 55 year olds
you can still think it's 12 year olds it
hasn't been 12 year olds for two years
that's the game of no versus the game of
yes
that's the game of staying curious
the biggest biggest vulnerability to
people in business today trying to sell
to human beings
is their unbelievable
calmness and interest in saying the word
no
and their visceral reaction to the idea
of maybe
the innovation that we're living through
is big
the opportunity is even bigger
but this requires homework
before you decide that content on social
media can't sell for you
did you really do the 20 hours of
homework and the 50 hours of you doing
it it doesn't count when you have your
niece do six posts for you
this world is reading about push-ups
instead of doing them
i wish actually that's not even that's
actually not even true i wish this was a
game of people reading about push-ups
and not doing it we're not even reading
about push-ups we're dismissing push-ups
before we even read about them
i ask you and implore you here today my
friends to open up your heart to
curiosity
to open up your eyes to the reality of
what's happening in our society and how
people are making their decisions
and to shed your preconceived notions
and start putting in the work for a lot
of us me included
it was easy to put in the hard labor
right it was easy to put in the work
it's much more challenging to figure out
the new technologies
the problem is the world doesn't care
about you and me
the world's gonna do what the world does
and the way people are gonna make buying
decisions are gonna be based on the
people they see here period
and the story and if you're not showing
up here in 2022 you're not showing up
it may feel good for you to see your
picture on a billboard
you might like it
but now you're servicing your ego
instead of your wallet
thank you
this is a very simple business
conversation
if you want to sell things it's a good
idea
to make it easier for people
to buy from you
and so the innovation is the mindset
the innovation is going home now and
deciding what you just saw in this talk
and saying is he right or is he wrong
and if you find yourself saying
he's right but i don't want to i really
mean this that's okay
but then you have to be honest with
yourself of where you are in your career
whether that means maybe doing something
else because you don't have fire for it
or
being content which is fine a beautiful
thing if you're content but you have to
be aware that this is all happening
around you
i i don't have to tell this room how
much innovation is going on in this
space you've got the biggest technology
companies in the world interested in
your money i know what the big tech
companies are doing
i know what's happening with blockchain
i know what's happening with the 20 year
olds that everybody makes fun of who are
picking up incredible market share from
a lot of you because they're actually
being seen on social they may not know
the [ __ ] business yet
and you love making fun of them for that
i got bad news for you that they'll
figure out
yeah no that's
that's may need to take a pause on that
one
people make fun of things until they
don't
everybody made fun of the kardashians
until they didn't
everybody made fun of tesla to they
didn't everybody made fun of my pictures
until they sold for a million dollars
today on christie's
congratulations
people love to make fun of things
and what i'm worried about is this
room's too successful
that's a great success
is the beginning of the end what are
some of those
you know you've you've spoken candidly
about your parents and the meticulous
upbringing what are some of the things
they taught you that now even get you to
sit here and give back in such a fashion
my
i think gratitude is the reason i give
back
i think the single reason i want to put
out all the content and
do things like
i'm very compensated for a speech like
this but no longer
does that make financial sense to me in
my business world it's just
amazing to be here with all of you
i love it
why
because i know how i communicate i know
that i come here with an agenda and that
agenda
is to suffocate one person in this
room's [ __ ]
with the hope that it's exactly what
they needed to go do something
so that in four years they could send me
an email and say i was in san diego in
2021 and i thought i was hot [ __ ] but
then you [ __ ] got me and then i got
my [ __ ] together
then i got my [ __ ] together and now my
family's so much better life and that
feeling for me is better than even when
i'm winning
so my my selfishness is my selflessness
it's fun for me i'm already good you
know it's very easy to give when you're
fulfilled
right and so
for me
what happened a
my family heritage was crazy [ __ ] up
my mom lost her mom at five my dad lost
his dad at 16. we lived in the soviet
union a lot of people don't know this i
didn't realize how many people don't
know this you weren't allowed to leave
the country the country was a prison
from 1918 to 1990 a prison you weren't
allowed to leave
leave
everybody spent time in jail
because the government owned everything
cuba and venezuela are a [ __ ]
vacation compared to soviet union in the
50s 60s 70s and 80s
so
you know here i am we left in 78 i'm
three years i'm growing up in america
but and this is gonna really hit for
this room i'm growing up in america but
am i really
because in my four walls it's [ __ ]
russia
right but but but i both right so in the
house all i'm hearing every friday night
and on the weekends is the stories of
the old country and it's a disaster
and i'm out here drinking coca-cola and
watching mickey mouse
and so
very quickly i'm just thankful
i'm just grateful and so gratitude was
big
the the other thing they taught me was
it the story looked like this sixth
grade nintendo explodes
right
and i'm like mom nintendo and she's like
good go get it
and so you know that framework
gets you serious about lemonade and
washing cars and shoveling snow and so
my parents taught me a level of work
ethic that i would in hindsight at 45
say is was probably too extreme the
three of us talk about it a lot i think
all of us collectively look at each
other and say maybe we took it to 130
100 would have been fine 80 would have
been fine we lived in 130 i worked from
the time i was 14 i worked every weekend
and every summer vacation day of my life
all of them like when people hear it i
don't think they understand all of them
not like kind of you know like you meet
people they're like they helped out in
their family business every day i was a
terrible student my parents sat me down
at 14 and they're like you're not going
to harvard so you're going to work every
day
and so so work ethic was taught and then
i had such a gift of
communicating that my father really
really impacted my life because he has
no tolerance for lying
and i had an incredible ability to
manipulate everyone on earth
[Laughter]
and when you're young and you realize
you have gift of gab you have no idea
how to fully function with it right and
so
my dad really helped me because i was so
scared of him
and for my father
embellishing or a slight exaggeration
was like a death blow
he keeps it so straight and that really
helped me a lot i i i think about that a
lot i was gifted with so many things but
i it really worked out for me on how
they parented me
but i but it all comes down to gratitude
when i tell you
the only thing on earth i care about is
the health of my family it is the only
thing i care about everything i do in
business is a game i don't give a [ __ ] i
[ __ ] money [ __ ] all of it health
and and
and
and when you really believe it when you
really believe it not on stage we clap
it's nice you know people that really
know me when you really believe it you
know what happens
this much pressure at work
mental health
my mental health is [ __ ] the greatest
of all time
because
at least you know in the scheme of
things from a business standpoint when
you genuinely mean what i just said
you don't have bad days
you have bad days because you're worried
about
money that's what it is you have bad
days because you're worried about the
money
and when you don't worry about the money
not because you have it or you don't i
feel the same way
i made i sold five pictures today at
christy's auction that made me more
money
than i made from being 22 to 34 years
old in my career combined
wow nice
that's that's not a humble brag that's a
but i was exactly the same way i am
right now at 30 at 26 it was just always
the game
and i i promise you
this is the big you know we talk a lot
about
inclusion in our society thank god
finally right and we we've we've been
attacking a lot of things in this
country the last 20 years sexism racism
immigration many many things that we all
know the one thing we are not talking
enough about in america is ageism
we love making fun of 70 year olds who
don't know how to use tick tock
meanwhile those [ __ ] understand life
there's a lot of wisdom
there's a lot of wizards and so the
reason i brought that up is you want to
get happier go hang out with 90 year
olds and really listen to what they talk
about you'll realize real fast most
things mean nothing
and once you realize most things mean
nothing
losing a deal means nothing